A graph data structure is a nonlinear
data structure consisting of vertices
and edges. They're used to solve many real
world problems and are commonly needed to
solve coding challenges. Harris from coding
cleverly teaches this graph course using Java.
Harris is extremely knowledgeable
in algorithms and data structures.
Hey there everyone, this is coding cleverly. And
today we're going to be talking about the graph
data structure. We're going to talk about how it
works, how it's constructed, and all the important
stuff we need to know about it. The first thing I
did was create three different files in the same
directory. Here I have graph dot Java, and then
we have vertex dot java. And we also have edge
dot java. And what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to actually write some code, and then I'm
going to try to interlink these, all three files.
Because this edge, this vertex and this graph are
going to be used together to create our graph data
structure. Before talking about graphs, I want to
talk about the graph traversals there are many
ways to traverse a graph, but you will focus on
three methods depth first search breadth first
search and Dykstra algorithm. These traversal
methods are core algorithms for searching a
graph. Now what are graphs graphs are the ideal
data structure for modeling networks, making them
an essential part of your data structure toolkit.
They are made up of nodes, or vertices, which
hold data and edges which connect to vertices.
A vertex is a single node. Now all of this
will be explained through the diagram. Here's
a sample of a graph that I created. These
circles everywhere are actually vertices,
and they're holding data and edges, which connect
to vertices. So these lines over here are known as
edges these things now I want to give an example
consider a map of your neighborhood. As a graph,
we could represent bus stops, as vertices and bus
routes, between stops as edges. So how about the
internet web pages can be thought of as vertices
and the hyperlinks that connect them as edges.
Real world relationships are represented as
graphs are numerous, making them an important
concept to grasp. The graph, which could see over
here is actually representing a social network.
People are vertices and edges are friendships.
So these lines are friendships. These circles are
the people Peter, Cody and Jordan are all friends,
Peter and Cody are friends. And the same goes for
Cody and Peter, Peter and Jordan are also friends.
And Jordan, all and Peter are friends as well.
So this bidirectional pattern is also existing
here, Jordan and Cody are friends. And Cody and
Jordan are friends. One other thing that we see
here is distinct, which is Caleb and Alex. Now,
these are friends. But these are not linked with
these people over here. Interesting. A path is
made up of vertices connected by any number of
intermediate edges from Peter to Cody, the paths
could be Peter to Jordan to Cody, or Peter to
Cody. There is no way between Peter and Caleb, a
graph is disconnected when no path exists between
two vertices. So this here is a disconnected
graph. Because not all of these vertices are
connected with each other, it's impossible to
reach here. So this is the reason why this graph
is a disconnected graph. Alright, so now let's
map out this concept in our code. Now, what we
want to do is we want to create a graph class
that could be flexible enough to support directed,
undirected, weighted and unweighted graphs. Now,
the difference between a directed and
undirected graph is that for directed graphs,
which is so this is an undirected, disconnected
graph, because there's no link here, and you can
reach here. So this is disconnected. The reason
why it's undirected is the reason that both of
these paths are like bi directional. So over here,
Peter and Jordan is Peter is friends to Jordan,
and also Jordan friends to Peter. So this
is bidirectional. So and this is undirected,
if it's directed, it would have arrows here.
So it would point that Peter is only friends
to Jordan. But Jordan doesn't like him back. And
Jordan is friends to Cody, and Cody doesn't like
him back. So something like that is going
to be directed. In case of weighted graphs,
you'd have weights on top of each. So I know it
doesn't make sense over here. But if we had like,
stopped, bus stops, and then their
routes, it would have been easier
and easy to map out. But here, if I say
Peter, and then Jordan, it takes like,
let's say five. So it's something like this. And
then we have over here we have, let's say 10.
And over here, let's say it's 12. So over here,
now we got weights on top of the edges. And these
are just going to indicate the number or the
expense that we're going to take here. So Peter,
I know it's not a good example, like I said that
we could have done with bus stops and routes,
but here we're at Again, Peter is finished
with Jordan. And I don't say five times. He,
he likes him five times this. Jordan likes Cody
10 times. And Cody likes Peter 12 times, I'm
not sure if that was a good example. But you you
got my point there something like that it with,
which associates the numbers as they're expensive
with this in mind, we will create our graph with
the following requirements of vertex can store any
data. So these circles, a vertex maintains a list
of connections to other vertices represented by
a list of edge instances. So we're going to have
a vertex, we're going to also have its list to
connect other ones. So those are going to be
called as these vertices and they're going to be
linked through the edges. So here we have Peter,
but friends are Jordan and Cody, right. So
we're going to have to put that in some kind
of structure here. So it's going to be a list
of edges. So they're going to be represented
by all this stuff, Edge instances, a vertex can
add and remove edges going to another vertex.
A graph stores all of the all of its vertices
represented by a list of vertex instances. So all
of these vertices you see, are just going to be
stored in that graph structure. Our graph knows if
it is directed or undirected. Like I said, this is
undirected. And if it had some kind of direction
it would been directed, a graph can add and remove
its own vertices graph can add and remove edges
between stored vertices with all of that other
way, let's write the code. So to keep the concepts
grounded in a real world application, we'll build
a transportation network of bus stops as we go,
what I want to do first thing is actually look
into my vertex class. And because I know this is
a circle, which has the data, and it's also
going to have the edges, so we're going to
start from this one. Here, we're gonna go into
this class vertex here. And we're just going
to create some instance variables. So the first
thing that I am saying is private string data.
Second thing that comes to the mind is private
ArrayList. Because we want to store the edges,
right, so we say ArrayList, we put the type of
the ArrayList here, so we're going to store edges.
So it's an ArrayList of edges. And we're going
to call this as edges. Alright, so now we're done
with that, let's add a constructor here, we're
gonna say public. And we're gonna say vertex.
Here, we're gonna have a string. And we'll
say input data, the data that the user will
provide. And then for that will take the class
variable is equal to the input parameter.
And then we have this dot edges, which is the
edges, and that would equal to the new ArrayList.
And here we want the edge. And we also want
this. So here, we instantiated the array list,
which was this edge is one. Now I know this
is giving us problems, because it's not
allowing us to have this. So let's just import
this import Java dot util dot ArrayList. And the
errors are gone. Here, we have a vertex
constructor that assigns the data with
the input data and also instantiates the
edges list with a new ArrayList of type
edge. Now we got these vertices right, now we
want to have a mechanism that will allow us
to see these edges in live action, right. The
other thing that I want to go through this is that
I'm going to create this as a directed graph. So
there's going to be arrows here, a method called
public void, add edge. And over here, we're gonna
add in the vertex and vertex and integer. Wait.
Alright, so now that this is done, and we just
created this constructor for this, I mean,
know the instance variables. Let's move on to
edge dot Java and create the instance variables
for here. And then after that, we're going to go
back to this vertex dot Java and finish it up.
One thing I want to make clear here is that I'm
going to create a directed graph. It's going to
be the ones that have the arrows, it's not going
to be the bi directional ones, which would go both
ways. It's just going to be one, one stop to the
other stop, right? It's a bus stop. So I don't
want to go backwards. So in this case, it's just a
directed graph. What we're going to do here is for
the edge, like I said, it's just a line where you
see in the graphical representation And by here,
I'm gonna have to try to map it out in code. So
I'm going to have the start vertex, where it's
coming from, and where it's going to. So PRI,
visit private vertex. And then we have the end.
And over here, we want to wait, we're also
going to create this as a weighted graph,
that will have a cost for how much expensive
will it take to move from one place to another,
remember those numbers which were on top
of those lines, so that's the weight here,
so it's going to be a weighted graph as well. So
I'm going to put up weight in here as well. And
it's going to be called integer. And I'm gonna
say W, RI ght, I'm going to put a integer Wait,
and notice I'm using integer and not int. It's the
reason is that if I don't want to put anything,
I could just type in null. And it would allow me
to just like Pass It On with no reason. And if I
had an integer, I'd pass in something like
minus one. All right, so now over here, we
have a constructor and I will say public edge. And
let's create the constructor here. So the vertex,
and I'll say the start vertex, so I'll call it
as the start being the vertex. And we have any
vertex or we have envy, we have the integer.
And we call it as the input weight, web ID.
So there you go. So we got the start
vertex, the vertex and the input weight
that we're going to ask the user for. So
remember, this is just an edge of that we
are creating as users. So the class variable,
the start star will equal to the start vertex,
which will be passed in as an input parameter.
The same thing goes for the disk dot end.
And it will equal to the end vertex, Jose
and vertex. And we have the way to so we say this
dot w e IG ht, and we equal that to the input,
w e, IG HT. There you go. So now we're done
with this. And let's just add in some other
helper methods. So I'm going to be adding some
helper methods along with this. And I'm just
going to be copy pasting this. So here, these
are the public vertex, get start. And it just
going to return the start vertex, the public start
vertex get and will return the end vertex of the,
you know the edge of what's in the edge. And
the integer gateway will just return the weight.
Okay, so that was cool. Let's go back to the
vertex dot java file, and just make some methods
here as well. So for the vertex dot Java, and
remember, like I said, we wanted to create a
function that will allow us to add some edges,
right, we're not giving the, we're adding a layer
of abstraction here. And we're allowing the method
over here, we'll just add it I just for us. So
what I could do here is I could say, a public.
And I'd say, void, add, II D, so II, add, add,
so add edge. And if we want to add an edge to a
vertex, so remember, the current vertex is already
in the context. So this will be the end vertex.
So I'll just pass in the end vertex here. And
also the weight if you want to give it some kind
of weight. Remember, I said weight is optional.
If you don't want to give it it will be assigned
as not to do something like that. First of all,
I'm going to have the call to this, I'm going to
say this dot edges, et je s, because it exists and
edges over here. And then there is a function that
was called add for the ArrayList, because edges is
an ArrayList. And we just add in a new ad G, and
we call in the constructor, so this constructor
will add pass in the this, it will get the edges
and a vertex, so it's going to be an vertex,
and will also be the weight of the edge. So all
of this will be mapped in here. So this is our
add edge, and it's gonna just gonna add some
edges here. All right, so now we're gonna have
to create the Remove edge here. So we're
gonna say public, and I'm gonna say void.
Remove Ed G, and we have vertex, and we
have an vertex. And over here we have
the, this dot EDG II, I just got removed. And
the method for this is, since it's a just as
an ArrayList removed if will allow us to add a
predicate and remove all of the elements of this
collection that satisfy the given predicate.
errors at runtime exceptions thrown during
iteration or by the predicate are related to the
color parameter here is a predicate. And here you
can read it. It says filter a predicate, which
returns true for elements to be removed. And I'm
going to add that predicate here. So over here,
I'm going to add in, so I want to remove that
vertex. So here I'm saying remove edge right And
I'm in that vertex. So I'm in the vertex, Java,
and I want to remove that edge that was passed
in as this one. So n vertex, right, I want to
remove that edge from here. So I would say, I just
removed if now say, I remove that kind of edge,
right? I know, we put this arrow bracket. So
this is an arrow sign, and I'm gonna say edges.
And then we say get added, because we're getting
actually, two things here, the edges are having
two places. One is the first. And the second is
the end. So you can see in the code over here,
we have the start and the end. So the edge
has two things. And what we want is the end.
So that's why we are getting the second one. And
that's going to be over there. So they'll get and,
and then we say dot equals, so we say if that
equals to the vertex that we passed in here, I'm
just gonna copy that and paste it here. And for
that equals, then just remove that from there. So
we just need a semicolon here.
If I could get a semicolon,
all right. And that should solve our problem here.
So it's just going to remove that end vertex that
we passed in as an input parameter. And it's
going to look at this, just dot remove if and
it's going to pass in this predicate logic that
says, find that edge, which has the end vertex
equal to the end vertex that was passed in pretty
easy. Okay, so now we're gonna add in some other
helper methods, I'm gonna copy paste this as well.
So I'll just paste it here. So the first thing,
let me just zoom out and show you what I've done.
Here, we have this remove edge, and we have the
Add edge perfect. Over here, we have this Get
Data method. It's a string return type. And
it's just going to get the data for the vertex
pretty easy, straightforward. And the ArrayList
edge. So this is the return type, and it's in
get edges. So it's just going to return the,
the edges that the certain vertex has. So it's
just going to return the list of it, this dot
edges. All right. Now over here, we have a public
void, print Boolean, show eight. So over here,
we have this printer method that's just going to
allow us to visualize our implementation. And it's
just going to show us how the graph is looking
like inside of our structure. So it's pretty
easy, you don't need to go into detail for
this. And if you want to write this down,
you can pause the video and start typing this in.
We're done with the edit of Java. And we're also
done now with the vertex dot java. In fact,
I don't even need this main method here. So
I'm just going to remove that here. And now we
just have this so the Virta edge dot Java and
the vertex dot Java are done. Let's go to the
graph dot Java, the main thing, the main boss,
so over here, we're just gonna add in the
following things. Remember, like I said,
a graph is a list of vertices. That's exactly
what we want to do here. So I'm gonna say private.
And I'm gonna say array list. And I'm gonna put
in the type here, the type for this is vertex,
because we're putting in vertices, and we're
going to pass in vertices like this has a name.
Now we also have a type, which I've specified
that there could be different kinds. And my
graph will be a weighted graph. So I'm just
going to put an is weighted boolean variable,
I'm also going to put is directed boolean
variable. And this is just going to tell me
if the graph is directed with arrows, or if it's
unidirectional, or bi directional. And so that's,
that's the thing. Let's create a constructor
for the graph. And we'll just say public graph.
Graph, and then we'll just pass
in Boolean. And we'll say input
is weighted. So the things that are passed
in will be determined by the user. And pool
Boolean input is directed. So with all of this,
and here we're gonna have the this dot vertices.
And we're gonna say new array list and we're just
gonna pass and so over here we have graph and then
we have Boolean, input his weighted, and then we
have input as directed. So like I said, we're we
have to first initialize the vertices array
list, so I'll just say new ArrayList vertex,
put the round brackets and then the
semicolon this will initialize our vertex.
This will initialize our vertices list and
for the weighted thing, so we can say is W E,
weighted is equal to and we say
input is weighted, so W E IG ht,
for the other one which is directed so is directed
is equal to input is directed There you go.
Cool. So now this is created. And yeah,
I have to import the ArrayList as well.
So just import that as well. Now let's create
some methods. And the important methods that
we want to do here is that we want to create
a method that will allow us to add vertex,
add some vertices to our array list. And the
name for that will be self explanatory. It's
called vertex. And that's the return type.
So it's going to be called add vertex. The
data that will be passed in was a string. And over
here, we'll say vertex. And we'll say new vertex.
And over here, we're just going to create
a new vertex here. So we'll say new vertex.
And we'll pass in the data that was passed in.
And over here, we're gonna put that inside of our
list. So we'll say this dot vertices dot add, and
we put the new vertex, semicolon. And then we have
the return new vertex. Cool. So we're done with
this, that's the Add vertex method. And it just
returns to us the vertex. So we'll have to assign
it to a variable in the main methods. So now we're
going to create the public void, add edge method.
And this will allow us to pass
in the vertex, vertex one,
the vertex, vertex two. So this is the start and
the end vertex and the integer way, like I said,
I wanted to create a level of abstraction here.
So I'm allowing our graph to have the Add edge
of functionality as well. So over here,
it's pretty straightforward. If I said,
if the thing is weighted, then there's going
to be no weight for this because I passed an
integer weight. And I have to first check the
boolean variable here. So if I say is waited,
not directed, but is W E, IG HT. Now if the
waiter was false, then so it says if waited,
is false, right. So we'll just say, the wait,
that was passing, it will be assigned as null.
All right. And if it's not false, meaning if the
thing is weighted thing, so we'll say vertex, one
dot add edge, and over here, we're
actually adding the vertex to.
And here the weight will be passed in as
well. And this is the Add edge method.
That's from the vertex class here. So the
vertex add edge, this one. Now, over here,
we want to actually add in the other thing around
as well, because we don't need bi directional
and unidirectional. So if it's undirected than
both right, and if it's directed than just one,
so I'll say if it's not directed than both,
so this.is directed if it's not directed.
Then we'll have the vertex, vertex two dot, add
vertex, or, yeah, so vertex two dot add edge,
here, we're gonna add the edge.
And we're gonna say, vertex one.
And we're also going to put in the weight over
here as well. And there you go. Similar to how
we created the Add edge method, we now need
to create the Remove edge method. So let's go
here a little down. And let's add the Remove edge
method. So we're just like I said, I'm giving the,
the power to the user to do all of this. So
and the user doesn't even have to know how
the vertex Java or Java works. So that's the
layer of abstraction that we're creating here,
remove edge, Ed EDG II, and over here, we're gonna
pass in the vertex. And we'll say vertex. So to
remove the edge, you'll have to need you'll need
the vertex one. You'll also need the vertex two.
Now to remove it, it's pretty simple. We say
vertex, one dot remove, this is the method
that was there. So remove edge and it takes
another vertex. And we have the vertex here,
we're just gonna pass in the vertex two. And there
you go. And then, like I said, we have to check if
it's not directed. If it's bi directional, then
we have to remove the other way around as well.
So I'll say if this.is done directed. So if it's
undirected, right, so if it's bi directional,
then after moving the other way around, as
well as using vertex two dot, remove edge,
and we put in the vertex one. Okay, so that was
pretty much it with the Remove edge. Now we have
some other methods like remove vertex, so just
add an empty move redex, quickly over here, void,
remove vertex. And for the Remove vertex, we
have the vertex that's passed in as like this.
And what we're going to do is we're going
to say this dot vertices, which is the list
that is existing here in this class, this instance
variable, and we're going to use the remove method
that's provided by the ArrayList. And we're just
going to remove the vertex that you just asked
for, right, so that's just going to be removed
here. Now to save some time, I'm just pasting
some helper methods that we also need here. So
I'll just paste that in. And let's see how it
looks like. So here we have the get vertices,
the remover index, the get vertices method,
it just returns the list is weighted, is directed.
So that the last thing we did was this one,
which was removed the vertex, and then after that,
this one is just to get vertices, it's just going
to return the array list vertex. So the whatever
the array list is, it's going to return all the
vertices here, inside of that current graph.
Public boolean is weighted will return if the
graph is weighted or not. And boolean is directed
will turn if it's directed or not. Public vertex,
get vertex by value, passing a value, and it will
loop through this. For condition, it's going to go
vertex. So you pass in a string value, and you try
to look for that vertex for that kind of value. So
let's say I have a stop in New Jersey, let's say
Jersey City, I'm looking for Jersey City, stop
for my bus, you know, bus route. So in the bus
service that I'm trying to map out here, let's say
I have Jersey City passed in here, now I'm gonna
have to look for that stop if it exists in this
entire bus ecosystem. So if it exists in the bus
routes, if if there is any kind of bus stop, that
has the name, Jersey City, and then it will be
returned here. So over here, I go for each loop,
and it says over here, the vertices are listed. So
I would say for every vertex v, if the value is So
I'll use the get the data value and this vertex,
remember that I created get data over here
somewhere. So it's supposed to be somewhere over
here, there you go, it returns a data string. And
if it equals to the value that was passed it as an
input over here, no more return the V vertex, and
then you'll have it as a vertex here. So perfect.
And if it didn't exist, it will just return null.
So that will help us know if the vertex exists
here. And now over here, if you want to print it,
so for vertex V in this vertices, v dot print,
and we have is weighted, so you know the print
method that we created here, this will allow us to
see all of these vertices in action. Awesome. Now,
let's create the main deal here. Let's create some
graph. Let's create the graph data structure. And
let's try to map it out. And I'm gonna remember
I said I'm gonna create a bus station. So I'm
gonna say gr, a pH. And I'm gonna say, bus
network. And I'm going to say, new graph.
And over here, we're going to pass in for
the is weighted, and for the direct fizzing,
we're going to pass in both true true.
So T, ru, E, and t, are you ready? Now,
let me tell you why it's this. The first one was
input is weighted, so it is weighted, there's
going to be values associated to it. So for every
edge of there's going to be some kind of distance,
and the input is directed, meaning that there's
going to be some kind of Arrow and it's so it's
a it's not bi directional. It's not two ways.
It's just one way going forward. So bus network.
And I'm going to use the advert x method that
we created here in this method. So it asks us
for a string data, and we'll just say that,
say, Clifton. And here we have a semicolon.
But remember that this add vertex method if
you go, if you go and see the method here,
it's actually returning a vertex. So we're gonna
have to store in some kind of barrier variable.
So let's store it in a vertex. And I'll
call this as Cliff Clifton station.
And it equals to that so there you go. And the
same goes for the next one. So I'll say bus
network, dot add vertex, and we'll say vertex.
And over here, we'll have the next station I'll
just add a caveman station. And let's have the
vertex here as well. So, vertex and all Say,
keep keep me station. And just There you go. So we
created two stops. And I think that's enough for
now. So now what we have to do is add the edges
and the connections between them. So we use the,
you know, the Add Agile method. So we'll
use bus network. And we'll say add edge.
And to add edge, we have to put one station to
the next Jose Clifton station, and we'll say,
the cape Main Station. So that's the connection.
And we'll also have to put a weight, let's put
a weight as well. So I'm gonna say it takes 1000
miles to reach there. And that's our weight. Cool,
now it's connected. And remember that I'm not
putting it. So I'm just putting it one way,
and it's just going to connect
it that, you know, directed way.
Here we have that, if I wanted to remove an
edge, it would remove it and using the same
but I'm just gonna say bus network dot remove
edge and his pet pass in the same two things,
not the weight that time. In this case, I just
want to print it out and see how it looks like.
So bus network dot print. And this is our
method that was that is created here. I'm
actually calling all the vertices, so it's going
to be printing it through here. Awesome. So let's
run this baby up and see how it looks like so I'm
gonna command from here. And I'm gonna say Java
seed. The name of it is called Graph. God Java,
it compiled. And now after that, I'm just gonna
paste here. So over here we have the direction
from Clifton to keep me and it takes 1000 miles.
So that's exactly what we did here. Let me just
minimize it quickly. And go back here. And if I
look over here, I actually created a direction
from clipped indicate man, it takes 1000 miles.
And I didn't do the other way around. Like I said
this was not undirected. It was directed because
it was such true. And here you can see that
there's just one way from Clifton to caveman to
1000. And I can't go from caveman back to Clifton.
And if I want to do that, I could easily do that,
I could just modify this so input is weighted,
that's set to true if I just leave this as
nothing. So by default, it will consider that as
false. So alright, so I'm just going to have to
if I add in false here, and that's just going
to make it undirected so it's gonna go both
ways around. And if I do this, now it's
gonna go bidirectionally. So I'll say this,
and then after that, so over here we have clipped
into Cape May 1000, and came back to Clifton 1000.
Using graphs to model complex networks is great
but graph search algorithms are another way graphs
can be useful. A graph search algorithm can be
used to traverse the entire graph data structure.
In search of a specific vertex value. There are
two approaches to using a graph search to navigate
a graph DFS and BFS DFS are depth first search
follows every possible path to its conclusion.
BFS on the other hand, or breadth first search
expands the search from the point of origin to
an ever expanding circle of neighboring vertices
to track down what we visited, we add a list this
list will be very crucial because it prevents a
search from returning to the same vertex multiple
times. This is especially important for cyclical
graphs, where you could otherwise end up in an
infinite loop. And we've seen this in our previous
videos. So you might be wondering, how does one
compute the runtime of graph search algorithms
in an upper bound scenario, we will examine
every vertex and edge. As a result, the big ol
runtime for depth first and breadth first search
is all of vertices plus edges. So you have the
O and you have bracket vertices plus edges. Now,
here's a question. What if you don't need to find
a path, but you do need to find a list of all the
values in a graph? What should be the solution
there? Well, it turns out that in addition to
pathfinding depth first search is pretty adept
at organizing vertices, or vertex values,
with a clear order of visitation from beginning to
end. So you could use depth first search to find a
path and you know, like, instead of pathfinding
about you go to organize and show the layout of
the complete graph structure. Using depth first
search there are three main traversal orders that
you'll come across for graph traversal, pre order,
post order, and reverse post order, also known
as topological sort, pre order, in which each
vertex is added to the visited list, and added
to the output list before getting added to the
stack. So that's just one thing to remember here,
in post order in which each vertex is added to the
visited list and added to the output list after it
is popped off of the stack. And then reverse post
order, which is also known as topological sorting,
which returns an output list that is exactly the
reverse of the post order list. So post order and
reverse post order are just like the opposites
of each other. Here I have a cool graphical
representation of a graph, take a look at this
directed graph structure that I've depicted here,
let's say that we want a list of all vertex
values starting with one in the order that
they are added to the stack. Now a pre ordered DFS
traversal would come in handy. Now over here, we
would assume that the algorithm prefers visiting
things in numerical order if there is a choice,
so our target value is one. And normally you would
get a target value from the program. So our target
value is one here. So we're starting with one,
we'll go with one. So this is the first thing
that's visited, this is also going to be on top
of the stack. So over here, if we have a choice,
we're going to prefer visiting the minimum number.
So over here, we have three and four, we're going
to check three, so we're going to go and visit
three. And we're also going to put it on top
of the stack over here. After that, we see that
there's four and two. So we're going to look at
the smaller number. And we're going to we're going
to visit it, so two is going to be over here, two
is also going to be over here. And then we're also
going to check for five. So because it's five,
and there's no other option, so we're going to
have to check five, we'll put on the stack as five
over here. And the visited will go over here as
well. Now the important part came, and you could
see that there's nothing after this. So we'll have
to pop this thing out of the stack. So we're going
to have to just pop it out like this. And now
we'll check to so two still has nothing with it.
So we'll pop that out as well. And then we'll
check three, so three has something so it has
thing that was not visited, and it was four
and it's not in the visited set. So we're
going to add that visit four over there. So
just add four to the top of the stack here.
And we're going to add four here as well. Now,
we're going to check for the four, and we're
going to see, well the four doesn't have anything.
So we're going to pop that out on the stack as
well. And then after that we have three, so we're
looking at for three something and a number that
is already that is not visited. So everything
is visited four and two are visited. So we're
going to remove three, we're going to look at one.
And if there's anything that is not visited, we'll
have to check. But there's nothing everything is
visited three and four are there. So we'll remove
that. So this is how our list will appear 13254.
So this is the pre order DFS traversal. Alright,
so like I said, that pre order is, is the kind
of order in which each vertex is added to the
visited list, and added to the output list before
getting added to the stack. So this was our pre
order traversal. Now we want to look at post
order traversal, in which each vertex is added
to the visited list, and add it to the output list
after it is popped off of the stack. So if we look
at take a look at the post order traversal, we'll
go like this. So for the first thing, it's one,
so we're just going to look at one, we're not
going to add it to the list or anything yet,
then we're gonna look at the smaller number
which is three, then we're going to look at
something even smaller than that, which is
two, then we're going to look at something
and then we have five. So there you go, the last
number came, so it's going to go like this five.
And then after that, it's going to go and see the
two because it's going to be popped off as well.
So five, two, and then we're going to look at
three. So three actually has something for this.
So we're going to have to add four. And
then we have nothing over here, so four,
and then we have back to three.
So back to three. And then we have
we have the last one, which is one. So this
is our post order traversal. This is how it's
going to appear. And the reverse post order,
which is also known as the topological sword
will return an output list that is exactly
the reverse of the post order list. So this
is a post order traversal. And the exact
opposite of this is 1342 and then five.
So this year is the reverse posed order, also
known as the topological sword. And these are
just different ways to traverse the graph. The
most common was the first one which was pre order,
and that's the default thing. And it's easy for
us to get a full overview of the graph like that.
Alright, so let's have a conceptual overview
of how the depth first search DFS is going to
work. So let's suppose we have our target value
as one. So we're gonna go and visit one here.
And we're also going to put it on the stack.
So that's the top of the stack, then we'll
have to look at the number that is smaller from
this choice. Over here, we got three and four,
we're looking at a smaller number. And we'll put
three on top of the stack here. And we'll put it
as our visited set as well. So we have three,
and then after that, we look at the smaller
number from these two, and the two is a smaller
number. So we'll put it in the visited set.
And we'll also put in the DFS stack. So we'll
put it up on the top over here. And now we can
see that five is the only option. So we'll have
to use five here as the visited. And then we'll
have to put five here on the top of the stack as
well. Since there's nothing over here on this,
there's nothing after the five, so we're going
to have to pop this out. So to do this, we're
going to have to just select this number and just
pop it out. And now we're going to look at two,
so there's nothing with two as well.
So we're going to have to pop this out,
three has some unvisited vertex, which is
this four, one, because it's not in the set
over there. So we're just going to have to use
this now. So we're going to use four, and we're
going to put it over here. So four is going to be
over here, and four will be on top of the stack
as well. Now we look at four, because this is our
current current vertex. And there's nothing over
here that's unvisited. So we're gonna have to
pop this out again. So let's just pop it out.
So there you go, this is popped out. And now
we look at three, there's nothing unvisited.
So we'll just pop this out, look at one, and
there's nothing unvisited, so we'll just pop
that out. Once the stack is complete from here,
so it's empty, we'll have a list over here 13254.
And this is a list of all of the vertices inside
of this entire graph. So we have 1325, and four,
this was our DFS depth first search. Now let's
write the code for this. So here I have a class
graph traverser. And it has a main method. And
also I have a sample graph that I've created
earlier. And it just contains up some vertices.
And yeah, it just has a method here that says Get
starting vertex. And we'll get the first vertex
here from the graph. Now, our job here is to write
the code for depth first, traversal reversals are
extremely useful when trying to find a specific
value or path in a graph. We'll start with the
depth first traversal method for recursively
traversing a directed graph. To summarize depth
first traversal, iterate down each vertex, one
neighbor at a time. In this video, I'll focus on
traversing the entire length of a single path, and
putting the data value of each vertex. Now in test
graph dot Java, I've created a sample graph for us
to test the traversals against this is all linked
to my last video about graphs. So we created a
graph here, and we have this input is weighted
as false and is directed as true. So there's no
weight, but it's directed meaning it's, it has
directions, right. And we have a vertex, start
node, and we have tests, we have now add vertex,
and we have the name. So these are the names
of our vertices. And yeah, so they're all these
vertices here. Now I have all of these vertices
that I added, and then I created these variables
to associate to them. And then after that, what we
did is add edges. So connections were done. After
that, we created a cycle here as well. And this is
not exactly the same graph that I've made in the
diagram. So what I have, what I have here in the
diagram was just simple so that you could easily
understand how DFS works. But here I just created
a complex one so that we could test out cycles as
well. And other things. After that, we have this
graph traversal dot java. To keep things simple.
I created a separate graph traversal utility class
in graph traversal, dot Java, and I'll implement
the traversal iterator as a static method here.
Now I've seen implementations in which they
created the iterator inside of the graph class. So
now let's start writing the code here in the graph
traverser dot Java utility class, we're gonna,
first of all, let's just add a method that is
for the depth first traversal. So we say public,
and we say static, because it's a static method
and void. And we're gonna say depth first.
Because we're using a static method here, because
this is a utility class. So depth first traversal.
And here, I'm just going to pass in
the vertex to start with. So a one I
need the very start vertex. And also I
need a list of all the visited vertices
for this start one, so that will be called
as an ArrayList. And I'm gonna put in the
vertex type here. And we're also going to put in
the name as visited, and then we have vertices.
Cool. So now we're done with this. Let's add
in the things here. First, let's just print
out the value of our start data. So we have
a system dot out dot print Island, and we say
start dot get data. So you might be asking, Where
do I get this get data from. So I already have
vertex dot Java included here, and I've created
this in my previous video. So we have a Get Data
method, and it's just returns the string data,
now that we're gonna have to iterate through
this vertex, and we're gonna check its edges, so
all of the edges for the start vertex, so we could
use an edge at V of E. So for all the edges E in
the Start dot get edges. So this is also a method
inside of the vertex class. So over here, I am
saying that for every edge inside of the start,
edges, so that's this means all of those,
all of those neighbors that are connected,
so we have to get the neighbor vertex to get that
we got to use E dot get. And, and this will give
us a vertex. So you can see that returned gave
us a vertex, and we're gonna save it as a vertex,
neighbor any igvh vor. Now, one thing to note
here is that this e is an edge and the get end is
from the edge class. So this is also here. So get
end is going to be somewhere over here, there you
go. And it returns the vertex, and from there, so
it's just pretty simple. This one, the end vertex.
Now, right after this, I'm gonna have a
conditional here. And I'm going to check if,
if my visited vertices does not contain this
thing, so I'm going to add it inside. So now
we even know. And we could, we could mark that
that we already visited or not to keep track,
if we visited vertices or not, we're going to add
this conditional. So if we're going to use visited
vertices, and then we say, dot contains. And
then we have the, the neighbor, and I say if
that contains inside of the visitor vertices,
because you know that the visited vertices was
passed here. And I'm saying if it's not inside
of the visitor vertices, then we want to add
it. So we'll just put a negation here. And let's
also quickly add this import. So just over a year
and quick fix, import the ArrayList as well
on top. Okay, cool. Now over here, in this
inside the conditional, I'm going to add in the
visited vertices, and I'm going to say dot add.
And I'm going to add in the neighbor
vertex here. So I'm going to say neighbor,
since our visited vertices holds the vertices,
vertices, and we could easily add a vertex here,
the really important recursive call here is that
we're gonna do a recursive call that will go to
the graph traversal again, so you're gonna call
the graph traverser, which is this current class,
and we're going to call the method which is depth
first traversal. And now it's requiring us a start
and visited, so the visit of vertices will be
the same thing. But now we're gonna go with
the neighbor. So an E, I VHBO. Art of so we're
done with that. And the conditional is done. And
here's the for each loop, it's going to iterate
through all of the edges for our Stryver index,
and it's going to go until it's done. So that's
pretty much it with our depth first traversal,
we could test it out in our main method,
we're going to create a test graph.
And we're going to say test. And what
we're going to say is new test graph.
Okay, so where am I creating this from this
is actually from this place. And this is just
creating a test graph. Remember, like I said, it
created this whenever this is a Public Test graph
constructor, and in the constructor is just doing
all of the work for us. So normally, we would put
this in a main method, but we're putting this
in a constructor. So it's creating a gigantic,
ginormous kind of graph with so many vertices.
So V one v two v one one, we want to all these a
1234567899 vertices, and they're connected edges.
And what's it going to do is it's going to show us
through this, so we're just going to create it
here. And we're going to pass it in. So before
that we actually need the starting vertex of
our test graph as well. And we have created this
handy method here, which was get starting
vertex, which returns us the first vertex
in our graph. So we could use test, and then we
say, Get starting vertex. And this would just give
us the starting vertex and we go save it somewhere
inside because of return. This actually returns a
vertex type. So we could say vertex, and we say,
starting vertex, so we'd say, starting vertex, and
we'll just equal it. Okay, cool. So now that it's
equal, now, we can add in the visited vertices. So
now let's add up the visited vertices list. So
array list. And I'll put the type as a vertex.
And I'll call this as visited vertices, visited
vertices. And here we're gonna pass in a new array
list. And here, we're gonna just instantiate it.
So like that, and a semicolon at the end. So we've
created a visited vertices array list as well. And
we're going to add in the starting vertex, because
it's already visited. So we're just going to add
it before all of the operations. And we'll just
add in starting vertex here. Cool. Now when it's
done, we're done with this initial thing. Now,
we could finally call our depth first traversal.
So this thing is really easy. It's the name of the
graph traverser dot depth first traversal. And
it's asking us for the start vertex. So we'll
say starting vertex, and the visited vertices,
and this should have printed out. So let's go
into this place, which is right here. And command
prompt it here. And let's go down and let's say
Java C, and we say, graph traverser, dot java.
And now let's just run it so Java graph for
a sir. So here we have, the way how this will
work. That's pretty pretty dope. Now it's time to
focus on breadth first traversal. As a reminder,
the breadth first traversal iterates through the
graph and layers, it goes down one layer, which
comprises the start vertex has direct neighbors,
then it proceeds down to the next layer, which
consists of all the vertices that are neighbors of
the vertices in the previous layer. And for this
example, I'll focus on traversing down one layer,
and then take a similar approach as we did with
the depth first traversal by keeping an array
of visited vertices to prevent us from iterating
through the same vertices over and over, however,
we will iterate through all of the direct neighbor
vertices instead of iterating. Down the neighbors
first edge, like we did in depth first traversal,
we will also use a queue to traverse through
the graph instead of recursion to explore the
different ways we can implement the traverse,
I'll reuse the same task graph that was used in
the depth first traversal implementation. Alright,
so what I have is a directed graph. And I'm going
to have to apply a breadth first traversal. So
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get my target
value, suppose we have it as one starting value,
and I'm just going to put it in the visited.
And I'm also going to put it in our BFS queue,
we're going to look at our adjacent vertices and
see the smaller number. So here we have three,
and we're going to choose that as the first one.
So we're going to say three, as our visited.
And we're also going to put three here as well.
Now that we've done that, we look at the other
adjacent one, which is four, and we're going
to add that in our visited set. And we're also
going to add it here in our queue. Now that we've
exhausted our current vertex, since there are no
more unvisited vertices, so we're going to have to
remove this one from our queue. So we're going to
remove this one, and now three will be our new
current vertex. And we'll look at the adjacent
ones here. So we have two and four, but two is
smaller. So we're going to choose two first.
And here we have two in the visited and two in the
queue. Now we also have four, but four is already
visited here. So we're not going to look at that.
Now that we've done this, we're going to have to,
since three is exhausted, now we're going to have
to remove that as well. So we're going to DQ it.
And we're going to now look at four now
four is over here, and there's nothing
that we could visit. So we're going to have
to remove this as well. So we'll remove four.
And after that we could see two is now our current
vertex, and two has a neighboring a neighboring
vertex, which is five, so we'll put five here and
it's the only neighboring vertex. So we'll just
put the BFS queue over here. So now that we've
exhausted two, we'll remove it from there as well.
And five is also nothing. So there's nothing with
five as well. So that's completely exhausted as
well. So here we have completely visited the
entire graph using breadth first search 1342
and five awesome now let's write the code for
this. So I'm going to the same file where I
created my depth first search and I'm going to
add my breadth first search right after this.
So this is my depth first search and right after
that, I'm going to create my breadth first search.
So I'm gonna say public. And we're also going
to make this as a static method. Since this is
a utility class and br E A D, E H, F fi rst and
then sc search. So depth first search. So breadth
first search, adding the vertex start, just like
that. And also the array list, which is the vertex
And this is going to be called the visited
vertices, just like what we did up on the
top for our depth first traversal. Now, since
you saw the graphical implementation there,
I use a queue. So I'm going to create a queue
here as well. So queue, and I'll call it visit to.
And here, we're going to equal it to new Q. So
Q u, u. And we'll just put that as well. Now,
you might be asking, where is it Q
coming from? Well, I actually have the Q
file here as well. So this is the queue dot
java file. And we've created queues before,
but actually modified here a little bit. So the
same exact queue that we've created in our video
series. But I just modified it a little bit,
just to add vertex as the data now instead
of a string or some kind of integer. So removing
that, and now let's just go here. And over here,
now we created our queue, it's called our
visit to, and we're going to have the visit to
dot n Q, the first thing, which is the start,
which was passed in as the input parameter,
and that's the vertex there. Now, we're adding
a while loop. And this is going to go until the
visit queue is not empty. So I'll say visit to
because this is a queue, it has this method,
which is empty, and I've created that one. So I'll
say if it's not empty, we're going to go inside of
this visit queue and keep doing those removing
queue things and, you know, traversing and
using breadth first search there. So for that, I
could, let's just get something down and actually,
DQ the, the elements in the queue, so we
could say visit. So we can say visit u.dq.
And here we have a vertex that we have to
do. So we'll put it inside of a current
variable. So we'll say current. All
right, so now that it's in current,
we could print out the value here, as well
as just say, system dot out, dot print.
ln, and then we say, you know, current dot data.
And there's a Get Data method that was in the
vertex class. So there you go, it's working
there. Now we're using a for each loop to go
through each of the edges inside of this current
vertex. Because that's what I showed you in the
graphical implementation. Now, I'm just mapping
all of that entire explanation down in code.
So I'm gonna saying edge for every edge of the
current vertex. So it's a current dot get edges,
which is returning an array list of
edges. And what we could do here is that,
so now we're gonna get the neighboring vertex of
the current vertex. To do that, we could easily
get it from E dot get an end. And that returns
us a vertex, that's our neighboring vertex.
And we pass it in to this vertex variable,
and we'll call it as neighbor. And over here
we'll apply a conditional. And we'll say if the
now since I'm using a visited vertices array list
over here in my input parameter that checks if
something is not repeated twice, so I'm saying if
it's not existing, so I'll say if visited vertices
dot contains. And neighbor thing, and e i g, h
vor. So I'm saying if it does not contain it,
then you should add it. So I'm saying, if
it does not contain that neighbor vertex,
then you should add it. So we'll
say visited vertices dot add.
And so visited vertices dot add,
and then we'll add in the neighbor,
vertex. Perfect. And then the last thing that
we could do here, because we created this visit
queue, and we'll include this inside of our visit
queue, so we'll just say visit cube dot n q,
which is this, and we'll put in a vertex data. So
we'll put in that vertex, which is the neighbor
and e i g, h, V o r, so this will be inside
of our visit Q, which is this queue, and it
just currently had only the start. But once you
get the edge of the neighboring vertex, you also
pass that inside of the visit queue. So that will
be now the current vertex and it will go until
there's a dead end and then we'll just remove
from the in queue and then so once it's exhausted,
like you'll see over here in this while loop, so
it's just gonna say until it's empty, not empty,
so it's just gonna keep going. And once it's
exhausted, like you can see over here DQ so
just see the other words sees that are there to
traverse. Now let's go Downey in the main method,
and just have everything over here set like this.
So just pause the video and type along. And over
here for the starting vertex test dot starting
vertex, here we have a ArrayList vertex visited
vertices, the same thing. And this is the same
exact thing. So instead of depth first traversal,
we're gonna say, be our breadth first
traversal. And the rest is history. And
compiling it and running it. Let me just label
them as well. So don't net out dot print, ln,
or we just have a line here, so print and then
we say d f s, I will say B, F s, run this.
So here you go. The difference between the two
of the traversal techniques here we have DFS at
the other side, we have BFS. So we have over
here 011, and something like that. And then
we have two over here, so something's going on
differently. But if you look at the total numbers,
1-234-567-8910 123456789, and 10. So the total
number should be 10. It's there's 10 over here,
and there's 10 over here. And if we look at
the test graph dot Java here, so the start
node 123456789, and 10. Awesome. So that was
it. That was my code for depth first traversal.
Welcome to another video, today we're going
to be talking about Dykstra algorithm. A very
important algorithm in the computer science world,
finding the shortest distance between vertices is
one of the most common applications of graph
searches. Finding this distance has a number
of applications, including determining the best
route to a destination and transferring data over
a computer network. Consider the graph finding
the shortest path between vertex A to vertex E may
appear simple in your mind. But telling a computer
how to do so is a bit more difficult. Fortunately,
there is an algorithm that computes the shortest
distance between any two vertices in a graph. This
is known as Dykstra algorithm. Now, let's look
at the conceptual overview of how the Dijkstra
algorithm is going to work, we're going to start
with the starting vertex. And you can see that the
start is pointing to eight. So this is my target
vertex. Here I have a distances cube, and also
have this unvisited, which is on the bottom. Now,
I'm going to look at the first step here in this
algorithm. And the first step is to pop off the
minimum distance of the unvisited vertices that
you can see over here, the minimum distance here
is zero, and these rest are all set to infinity,
meaning that the distance from A to itself is
zero. And the distance from A to any one of
these vertices is infinity for now. And if we look
at the minimum distance, right now, it's 00. So
we're going to pop this off, so we're going to pop
it off from here, and then we're going to look at
the adjacent vertices corresponding to this first
vertex. So you can see over here, so from A to B,
the distance is four. Now if you compare this with
the original distance, which is infinity, now four
is less than infinity, so we could replace this
infinity with four. Since we replaced that now,
we could also go and check the next corresponding
distance, now A to C has a weight of two. Now
you can see that two is less than the infinity.
Now, we can also replace this infinity with two.
Now we're done with that. And we're going to this
is our first iteration of the algorithm. Now we're
gonna go to the next iteration. So now we're going
to pop off the minimum distance of the unvisited
vertices. And you can see for now, we can see that
too, which is the for C is the minimum vertices,
we're going to pop that out from here. And we're
going to start with C. So you can see C has
at A, C only has one neighbor, and that
is E, and the distance from c to E is one,
and you have to look at the distance from A to C
two. So the agency was to and from C to E was one
total distance from A to E is three, so two plus
one is three. So what we're going to do here is
we're going to make from A to E as three and then
we're going to look at the E portion and we got to
see that three is less than infinity. So we're
going to replace this infinity with three. Now.
Since there is no more neighbors left, we're
going to need to do the next iteration for
this out Rhythm C has no more neighbors. So now
we're going to pop off the minimum distance of
the unvisited vertices, you can see now that
the minimum distance is three, so it's an E,
so we're gonna pop this off, and we're going to go
to E and look at the, the neighbors for each. So
E has only one neighbor. And that is indeed, the
wait for that as five, the distance will be three
plus five, which is eight, and eight is less than
infinity. So we can replace this infinity with
eight. Now that we have replaced that, we can also
see that there is no more corresponding vertices.
So we could stop here and do the next iteration
for the algorithm. Now, we're going to pop up the
minimum distance of the unvisited vertices. So you
can see that the minimum distance is b. So we're
going to pop this off. And over here, we're going
to look at the corresponding neighbors. Now B has
one, two, and three corresponding neighbors,
we're going to start with the first one, which
is C. So B to C is one. And now you can see that
from A to B, which was already existing was four,
and from there to see it's one, so five, so from
A to C will be five. And if we look at the C,
it already exists here, and and you can see
five is greater than two, so we're not going to
change this value, then we're going to look at
the distance from B to E, and that's three. So
from A to B, it's four, and from there to E, it's
seven. So if we look at the distance from A to E,
that should be seven. And that is greater than
the value that we already have here. So we're
not going to change that at all, either. Now we're
going to look at the last and final neighbor of B,
and that is D, now we look at the weight, this
is two, and the distance from here was four, two,
so it's going to be from A to B, it's four, and
from B to D, it's going to be two, so the total
distance here from A to D will be six. And we will
look at the distance over here that is actually
lesser than what we have existing. So we could
replace this eight with six. And that now will
be the end of our iteration. And now we'll go to
the next iteration of our algorithm. Now we're
going to try to pop up the minimum distance of the
unvisited vertices. Since we only have one versus
left, which is D, I will look at the minimum
distance here. And that is the minimum distance
rest everything has been visited. So that's D,
so we're going to try to bring it up, pop it
off. And we look try to look at any neighbors
for D but there's nothing. So that's the end
of our algorithm there. And that's how Dykstra
is algorithm is implemented. So you went over
there and saw all of the possible distances for
so from a to itself, the minimum distance is zero,
from A to B, the minimum distance is four till
here, from A to C, the minimum distance is two,
right here, from A to D, the minimum distance
is six, so, four to two here, and from A to E,
the minimum distance is three, so eight
to eat at the minimum distances three.
So, that sums up our dexterous algorithm
conceptual overview. Now, we're going to start
writing the code for this. But before getting on
to the code, let's think of what we should add
in or what objects and what structures should we
create. Looking into this algorithm. We're going
to instantiate a dictionary that will eventually
map vertices to their distance from the start
vertex. So like you can see over here we're going
to put that in a dictionary. A quick recap before
we start the code for this Dykstra does algorithm
finds all of the shortest distances between a
starting vertex and the remaining vertices in a
graph. The algorithm operates by keeping track
of all distances and updating them as it performs
a breadth first search Dykstra the algorithm is
implemented in all of E plus V of log of V, and E
means edges. And v means vertices, we will first
implement the algorithm to find the shortest
distance to every vertex. So let's go through
the code and all of the conceptual overview
that I gave. Now I'm going to try to map this
out in code. So here I have imported java util dot
asterisk, meaning I'm importing everything that's
available in the utility package, and have it over
here that you can see is public class Dykstra,
and there I have a main method. Here I have a main
method, which is actually creating a test graph.
And the weighted and directed properties are set
to true. And we also add these vertices here,
so A, B, C, D, E, F, G, and we also add their
connections to each other. So those are done.
So what we mainly have here is a test graph
in our main method to test the output of the
method. What we're going to create in this video,
so we're going to try to create that method,
which is called Die extras. So for that, we're
gonna have the public and we're gonna say static
dictionary And we put in this. So we're going to
return an array of dictionaries. And I'll tell you
why we're doing this in just a second. So here
we have the name of the algorithm, Dykstra, and
we're going to tell the parameter to add in these
two values. First thing is to have the graph. So
d r a p h, and we call that as G, we also need to
pass in a vertex. And that will be will be called
as starting vertex. So we're done with these two
input parameters. Now, we're going to create two
dictionary objects here. And one will be used for
the distances queue, the other one will be used to
keep track of your previous vertex. And this is
very crucial in this algorithm, we're gonna make
a dictionary and a dictionary is just a base of
key value pairs, we have a string, which is the
key and integer as the value. And we call this
as distances. And we create a new hash table.
And we put in these angle brackets and the
round bracket, and then we semicolon at the end.
So that's the distances Q. Now
we also need another hash table.
And this one will be for the
previous. So we add this as well.
And for this, we're not going to have
the integer as the value but the vertex,
this is going to store the data, and the also
value that exists. So like I was doing it over
there in the diagram, this A, and it maps out to
zero, and this b that maps out to four, so the
string is the letter, and the value is going to be
the integer. And for the second dictionary, which
is previous, it's gonna keep track of the previous
vertex. So that will have a string, which is the
current vertex, and vertex will be the previous.
Now, we also need to add in a priority queue.
So I have added some files here. And this isn't
one that's called queue object dot java. This is
actually a class that implements the Comparable
queue object. And you can see that it has the
vertex and the priority as class variables. And
you can see the, the constructor is actually
creating this object, and it's overriding the
compare to method with some priority base. So if
it's equal in priority to the input parameter, we
just return zero. If the class variable priority
is greater than the priority that was passed in
is, then we will return one out, we will return
minus one. So this is just just a file. And it's
just a fancy queue. It's just known as a priority
queue. The main difference between this queue and
the priority queue is that this will look at the
smallest value, smallest possible value, and it
will allow us to pop that one off. So like what
we're trying to do here, we were trying to look
at the minimum value and the where you're trying
to pop that off, that exact implementation is
priority kilojoule for us and without writing
extra code. So that's one of the biggest benefits
for using that. So let's add the priority queue.
And this is the priority queues. priority queue.
And we're gonna add in the queue objects here.
So if qu e we are gonna say, object that we
created. And then we got ADD name for that as Q,
Q, U, e, u e, is equal to now we're going to
add in the new and it was a priority queue.
And here, we're just going to add in the queue
object once more queue, you deal with obj eects,
and then a semicolon at the end of perfect.
So this is our priority queue created. And
I'm just adding the same exactly, just
after that. Now, you might be asking,
well, the priority queue is actually empty
right, now we got a queue something inside.
Now the thing that we're going to queue inside
for the first thing is the starting vertex,
since we know the distance for that is zero to
itself. So we're just going to queue that up
in here. So to say qu e dot add. And here
we're just going to say a new Q object.
And we're going to pass in the vertex V and
the int p, which is the priority of the vertex
v is just going to be the starting vertex.
And the priority for this would be zero.
Awesome. Now we're gonna try to iterate through
this entire graph that was passed in as an input
parameter. And we're going to try to iterate
through and try to find all the vertices here. So
we can use a for each loop for this purpose, we're
gonna say, for every vertex v. So we can say,
for every vertex V, in the G dot, get vertices.
And this is returning an ArrayList of vertex. And
you're just doing this really easily. And this is
also added here. So I have a graph dot java file.
And this is also added. So that's why I'm
able to get the method get vertices. So
this is get vertices. And it should be over
here. So we're good vertices. So this is the get
vertices method. And I'm also adding this edge
dot Java as well as this vertex dot Java, you
could look at my older videos. And from there,
I'm actually using all of those classes that
have created in the graph dot Java, the vertex,
dot Java, and the edge dot Java are all done in
a single video, which was called graphs in Java.
So watch that video. And for this cool object,
I'm just gonna let you see this code for now, you
can just pause the video and copy this. And once
you have all of these, we could go back here
in the Dykstra dot Java, and we're just going
to iterate through the vertices which are in this
graph, which was passed in as an input parameter.
Now, we're going to have to iterate through this.
And we're going to actually update our distances,
which was over here. So we're going to actually
have to update our distances and previous
dictionaries. So we're going to try to add all
these vertices from this graph to this distances
and previous dictionaries, we could do. First of
all, we don't want the starting vertex to have a
maximum integer of max value, because we know
that the starting vertex to itself is zero. So
we're going to give a condition here and say,
if the vertex you get is the starting vertex,
and this is just going to work. So we're
gonna say if that one is the starting vertex.
We don't want that. So if it's not, right, so
we want to update the distances, and we're going
to have to add input. This is a method available
in the dictionary. And this is, this allows us
to add a key and value pair. So the string is
the key, and the value is the integer. So what
we could do here is for the string, we could say
V, which is the vertex, or we say golf dot get.
So we could say, Get Data, and that will return
a string here. And this is also added in the
vertex dot java. So that's why it's working here.
And for the integer, we're just adding the maximum
or we want to use the infinity symbol, right,
we're going to use integer dot max value, this
would give us the maximum value for the integer
in Java, and that will be stored inside of the
value pairs. So key values are done. And for the
other case, where we have the previous dictionary,
so we'll say previous, previous a previous output.
And for this second dictionary will also have a
key value pair, but the value is a vertex. So the
key is going to be the get data, the same thing.
But for the value in this case, will be the
previous vertex so that we could keep track of
this. So we're just going to add in a vertex that
will be set to null for now. And then after that,
we're going to update it inside of our code. So
right now just set everything to know, including
the starting vertex. All right, so right after
this, we needed to add in the starting vertex here
in our distances, because we don't have it. So to
do that, we'll just add in the distances again.
That was a foot. And now we want to add in
the key value pair for that. And for this add
in the starting vertex, and we actually need
the value for this, I'm gonna say, Get Data,
and that will give us the string data. And for the
value, I'm not going to give the maximum value,
we're not going to give infinity because if
we look at this code over here, initially,
it was set to zero, so we want to just set it to
zero here, I'll put it there. And there you go.
So we created this entire thing, what you can see
over here, so you can see this entire thing that
we've created, which has a set to zero, and the
rest are all set to the infinity or the max value.
Now, let's go back. And we're going to
actually do the second step for this
algorithm. Now it's the fun part. We're going
to have to iterate through the while loop. And
we're going to check if the queue is not empty.
So we say qu e u e, this, this is our priority
you I will say the size method here. And if
we say of that size is not equal to zero.
We're going to do Do some operations inside of
this queue. First of all, we're gonna get the
current vertex here. And that is pretty simple Q
dot call, retrieves and removes the head of this
queue, or returns null if this queue is empty.
So we're gonna actually remove an item from the
queue using this method. And we want the vertex
here. So we just say the vertex, because we had
this over here as this queue object, and we
wanted to vertex here. So we're removing that
from the priority queue. So the first thing will
just be the starting vertex. And that was added
in our queue. So this was added over here to
to Add New Objects, starting with x with the
value zero. So that was zero was actually it's a
value to itself. So this is now set to current,
and we removed it from the queue.
Perfect. Now we're going to iterate
through this current variable, which is the
starting vertex. So we're going to look at
all of the edges or the neighbors for a
year. So we say, for every edge of Eid.
And we say, mapping out to the current
dot get edges, which is the ArrayList,
returning of edges. So for every edges, or every
neighbors inside of this current, so every edge,
an edge contains vertices, remember, so we're
actually going to first look at the value of what
the edges giving us remember, like I did in this
first one, that we were looking at the values,
and we also judging inside of our distances. So we
looked at, let's say, for, for the distance to D,
we had some already included distance was 215,
which was eight. So that was already passed in.
But we also want to keep track of the newer one.
So this is like four two, which is six. And now
this is an alternative one, we have to add that
somewhere, and then we have to judge something
like if it's less than the original one, then we
could replace it. So we won't have an alternative.
And we want to also have the original. So for
the alternative case, we'll add in an integer.
And I'll say alternative. And I could
add the distances here. So distances,
and this is the distances dictionary, and I'll get
the current dog get data. And that is the string.
And we also want the plus to the eat, get wage,
so we're going to get the weight as the end. So
this is the distance from the current distance of
the variable and the edge distance. So what this
means is, whatever the distance is existing for
this current nugget data, the starting vertex is
actually zero to the distance where it's leading
to with its vertex. So the edge where it's leading
to with its edge, it's make sense because this is
zero to itself. But if we're moving forward, we
have an edge with it, and we have some weight, so
we're adding that weight as well. So get weight.
That's the alternative. And we all
need a reference to our string,
neighbour variable. So we got to have that as
any igvh vor. So this is our neighbor value.
And we just have to keep it just keep it inside.
So we could eat, get and so this is the vertex.
And we want the value for this. So we
have Geat EDA and we have get data.
So over here, it's pretty simple, we have a
neighbor value, and we want to have the edge
vertex. So we want to have the edge and we want to
get the end. So we're gonna get the vertex through
this. And to get the data, we just say this, so
we're gonna get the vertex through this get end,
and we're gonna get the data so that string is
actually stored in the neighbor value. Now that
the string is stored, we could use a conditional
here to check if the alternative value is lesser
than the original value. So what we're gonna
do here is pretty simple, we'll say alternative
is less than the distances and we want the
dictionary so this is the distances dot get, and
we want to get the value for this, we can just
use the neighbor value, so that's why I stored it
over there, so that we can get the value of their
neighbor value. Alternative value is less than our
neighbor value. So what we're going to do is that
neighbor value is actually the original distance
that was stored inside of our distances object
which is on top. So over here we have distances.
If that is possible. We're just trying to override
it and so we're going to say distances dot put
it I'm going to get the neighbor value. So
that exact neighbor value, but we're going
to change it the value to the alternative. So
we're going to get the key and the value. So
this is the string neighbor value, and then the
integer will be now the alternative distance.
Also, we're going to have to modify our
previous, so we're going to have to add in
the neighbor value as well. So for the neighbor
value, we actually need the previous reference.
And the previous reference will now be for our
current instance, with the current one, which
is now which is actually starting vertex will
be the previous vertex for our neighbor value,
which is the current one over there. So it's
just gonna keep iterating this and updating our
previous reference. And the last thing, what we
want to do is we want to add the neighboring value
to our two u two u, eu object, and we have to add
in the vertex here, so we're gonna say e dot get,
and so that's just gonna give us the vertex
here. And to get the priority, we could say,
the distances structure dot get. And to get the
value, I'm just going to add in neighbor value,
and that will give us the value. So this is
a neighbor value is the key, and it will give
us the value which is associated to this key. And
that will be updated to our cue. And that's going
to be our priority. So that will be added. And
once it's done, we're actually going to break out
from this for loop when all of these edges are
done. And that will be updated. And after that,
until the wild size is not less than zero.
So this is just a line that will pop off the
minimum distance of the unvisited vertex. And the
rest is history over here, what you saw all in the
conceptional overview, everything is happening
and adjusting, and the right at the end, so
when the while loop breaks, so that I Dykstra
is requiring us to return a dictionary array,
right? So we want to return that. So over here,
right after the while loop, we could return
a new dictionary. And so over here, we're going
to return a new VI, C T, IO N ar y. And we're
going to get this way racket over here, which
is the array for this dictionary. And this is
the array of the dictionary. And we want to pass
in the distances, distances with the previous
structure here, this is a return statement,
we're going to return a new dictionary,
and it will have the distances and the previous
dictionaries. So we'll have both the distances
and previous dictionaries inside of this
dictionary array, which is returning here
in our function. So we're going to hear that
dictionary arrays returning. So this is the
return statement at the end. And yeah, so
that was pretty much it with this function.
This is minimizing it, so you can see the entire
thing. So this is the entire method for extra.
Now, we also have this helper method on this
bottom, so I'm just going to paste this in.
This is called the Dykstra result, printer method.
And what it accepts is an array of dictionaries,
well, how convenient, we're just going to use
this entire thing, I'm just going to return it
and so we can pass it inside of this. And this
will just actually print all the distances. So
what you'll see over here, so it's gonna
print out the updated distances like this.
And it's also going to print out the previous
positions. So you're going to see that as well.
So since the these both were dictionaries, we're
going to use enumeration as keys to get the values
of all of this and it's just going to give
us the key and value pairs, and it's going
to be pretty cool. So these both are going to be
allowing us to print these structures. So we're
going to add this process here. So let's just
create this call. So we had this test graph.
And what we want to do is we want to use this
method here, which is Dykstra. To use this we
have to pass that inside. So we're going to use
Dykstra here. I ran a passing the test graph,
alternate paths in the starting vertex, and that
is a because over here is the first vertex and
that's going to be our starting vertex. You
can set anything you want later on. And then
after that, we're actually calling this inside
of this method, which is dexta result printer,
since it's accepting a dictionary array of
D, so I'm gonna paste this thing inside,
and we're gonna wrap it around the Dykstra. So
there you go. And this will just print out the
things. So cool. So now let's run this code. So
let's go and add an CMD here. And let's run this
code. So Java C, ed i j, k, s t r a dot java.
And now let's just run it using Java DIJKSP
Ra. Alright, so we have an error here, something
no pointer exception, okay? What's the shortest
path between two vertices. To calculate
that we'll just create a new method here.
And we'll call this as public static, void.
And we'll call this as shortest path between.
Inside here we'll have a graph DRA
p h, and we'll call as graph G,
we're also going to have the vertex,
and we're gonna get the starting vertex.
And we also need the targeted vertex.
So we're gonna say, target work at x.
Here, we have the shortest path between method in
which we're going to input the graph the starting
vertex and the target of vertex because
we want the minimum distance between two
vertices. So we're gonna use this method for
that case, we're gonna have the dictionary
array object here, and we're going to
call this as Dykstra has dictionaries.
And that will be equal to the dictionaries.
So we're going to call the extra method here,
we're going to call it using the graph and the
starting vertex. What actually it gives us is
the distances and the previous dictionaries. And
I'm getting an error here. It's actually di J.
The method Dykstra is defined for undefined
for the type Dykstra. So the reason why I'm
getting an error here is because I don't have a
k. So di, j, k. And if I do that, I'm all set.
Now we want to put the distances and
previous in their own variables. So
we're gonna have the scope for that.
So I'm gonna say, distances dictionary.
And it will contain all the values which we had,
and then we're gonna manipulate this. So we're
gonna say dictionaries. So Dykstra, D ij, k,
s, t, R, A, and we have Dykstra dictionaries.
And we have this sub zero, that will contain
our Dix distances. And for the second one,
and for the second one, we could have
that as one. And that will be our previous
awesome, to get the distance of our target
word that we're gonna say distances.
docket, and we need to get the target vertex. And
we want the value for that we can say get data,
that will return a string. And that will actually
map us to the value from our distances, which will
be something like, you know, the value of what it
will take for us to reach from A to that point,
and that we could store in
some variable called distance.
So make sure you have the type set to
integer here. And then that should go away.
Now, what we want to do here is we want a
print screen, that will just show us the
shortest distance path between these two. So
what we could do is, we could paste this in.
And this is just going to print out the shortest
distance between the starting vertex get data and
the target vertex dot get data. So just in between
the two vertex, this is just going to give us the
letters, you know the distance between A to
whatever. And system dot out dot print ln will
just print us the distance, which was inside of
the target vertex. Now we actually need the, the
generated path that we should follow to create the
path, we're going to create an ArrayList for us.
And that will be of type vertex. And we will
call that as path we initialized an ArrayList
to get the target vertex and assign it to a
variable is very important here. So we're gonna
have target vertex and assign it to a variable.
So we're gonna go from the target vertex to the
starting vertex. It's a bit like the reverse
linked list. So we're going to use some kind
of functionality like that. We're going to use
a while loop and we say while the V, the vertex.
So if the V is data, and the Get Data will pass
in a string I'd say that is not, no, because we
know that the first one which has started will is
no, we're gonna add in the path. So the path is
actually the ArrayList, we're gonna say the path
dot add, we're gonna add a zero here, because
the path is actually making us add something
inside of this. So we're going to add in a zero.
And this will mean that it will be popped in the
for direction, it's not going to go backwards,
it's not going to queue there. But every time a
new value exists, it will come in the beginning,
every time a new value is added to this
ArrayList, it will be added in the beginning.
So patha, add zero will be added. So every value
will be added to the beginning of the queue,
not the end. And the other thing that we
want to do is we want to pass it that VT,
so that vertex that we set up will be also
passed in here. And then the next step here is to
get the previous instance here. So we can say
previous structure, which is a dictionary,
dot get. And what we need is the data here, so we
say v dot get data. That would give us a string,
previous dot get, and we got the value
over here, and we're going to assign that
to the vertex. So since we have that get
process here, we actually need the vertex here.
And that will assign it to the vertex. So
it's just going to keep going like that.
After this while loop, we could just print out
system dot out dot println in the shortest path.
And what we'd have now is the shortest path
as well. So we could go from vertex path
vertex to from the path structure, which is over
here somewhere. So vertex path vertex. So so we
have this path, which is this entire array list
that now contains all of the vertices for that
directed path. Now all we're going to do is
iterate through this for every path vertex,
we're going to print path vertex dot get
data, and I will just print the letters of
the port corresponding path. Now the only
thing that I'm going to do right now is,
like I said, I called Dykstra dot Dykstra
result printer, and I passed in these two.
So what I happened here was that I was on an
error. And whenever I was running this code, I was
getting this error over here at line number, 26,
and 94. So over here in line number 26, and 94,
it doesn't give me any clue of what's happening.
But you could tell that alternative is less than
distances dot that get the more value. So I was
looking at the alternative value very carefully,
here, I noticed that I did get an error while I
was doing this. So this is actually a syntactical
error, I was trying to get the alternative
path distance, and I was getting the value
from the distances dictionary, and I wanted to
current dot get data. And this is what's gonna,
this was going to actually give
us the value for this one. So
I didn't need this parenthesis over
here, I actually needed that closed here.
And now it was just going to give us the value
here, which was string. So it was going to give us
the value of that current data. So it's just going
to be an integer here. And then that was going
to be added with the edge dot gateway. So that
will also be an in so both of these ends added
will result in this alternative value. So
now it's proper. And if I run the code now
you can see now that this created it for
me. So here what I had was these vertices,
12345677 vertices, and these were the
connections to them. I just called the
Dykstra nothin past in the past graph, and
put in the starting vertex. After that,
I use the shortest path between method.
And this is all showing up pretty cool.
So now we're gonna test it out and see over
here that the distance is, is updated. And
it's according to what these vertices are.
So these are, I believe, seven vertices,
and over here we have the connections to them. So
you can see a is connected C a is connected to b,
a is connected to D, I want you to see over here
is that the previous here we have a as no and the
rest, when I said a is connected to B, D, and C,
if you look at B, D, and C, they're all connected
to a, so d is connected to a. So over here,
you can see that this is the structure here,
where we have all these vertices and their
corresponding values. So these are all the
values that have been have been updated. So the
distance from A to itself is zero, the distance
from A to D is minus 30 A the distance from A to
F F to 3020. So we just pass it these values here,
and then just allowed us to get the minimum
distance from this graph to just telling if the
distance from A to B is slope. So the minimum
distance from A to B is three, the minimum
distance from A to D is four and so on over here
in the previous, we have a has a previous of No,
but the rest vertices show their previous vertex
as well. For the last method that we created,
we want to call that shortest path between task
graph. And we've got the starting vertex and the
target vertex. Now we want the path shown, and
also the shortest path. So what we can do is
short paths, we pass an A and G. And this is going
to call this method over here, which is going to
call that method and it will return us some cool
looking path here. So we'll clear the screen and
then run it and then see the shortest path here
we got the shortest distance from A to G, which
is correct, we got a to g, and it was minus 38,
the shortest path and it showed how it was working
here, so A to D to eat to G. So if we map this out
and draw this in a diagram, or if we look at it,
everything will be correct according to these
results. And that actually sums up our video